uh what was the most nervous you've been
to shoot a video
oh man nervous
honestly damn I don't want to be that
guy saying I'm never nervous but
um
man honestly when I shot Tiffany haddish
with Russ I was like yo this is Tiffany
[ __ ] Superstar actress she's a you
know she just dropped a movie with
Nicholas Cage exactly great movie yeah
so far and I was like I was like all
right so like like and I'm directing
dialogue and I'm just like this is like
a surreal moment for me and I'm like
Edgar it's time yeah that's a real
moment I said it's time to show up you
know and the way we got Tiffany is funny
because um I got invited to this macro
event
um and they throw this big pre-oscores
parties with all these celebrities and I
was talking to Russ I'm like yo we need
to put a superstar in this uh like an
actress or something right someone's
gonna give it like notoriety and Russ
wanted to kind of be a little bit more
like funny and he's like everyone takes
me too serious I want to you know loosen
up a little bit and kind of like have
some dialogue so I can show people that
I'm actually just I'm this is who I am
right and um we're at this Prius parties
and I'm like yo Russ
Tiffany haddish and we walked up to her
and that's when we locked her in for the
video shout out to Jerome shout out to
Stephanie for connecting us but yeah we
saw her and we're like yo we went you in
the video and she's like she I don't
know if she knew who Russ was or maybe
she heard of him but she was like I'm
down and then she honestly she was down
to do it out of love too but then Russ
was like no I'm gonna pay you because I
respect your time and your energy and
your efforts so that was really
respectful for him